last time the years were at the coliseum
chris bassett had a complete game
shutout very emotional night for him but
his next start was up in seattle with
just four innings left trailing four to
two however thanks to jesus jesus
lizardo the bullpen
and how about 10 runs the last three
innings got a no decision so good for
him
just four innings in that start so he's
ready to go tonight against the
diamondbacks wind up and here's the 2-2
pitch and that's swung on in one hopper
to second in right field is elvis and he
throws him out in the shift so elvis was
the middle man between olson and lowry
and he was about 30 feet out in right
field makes the play and rojas
is retired officially 6-3
here's katel marte switch hitting center
fielder now the 0-1 and that's why i'm
going to come back off the glove of
basset cameras backhand lowry throws to
first for the out i think chris got a
piece of that i think that's going to be
a 1-4-3
good job reacting to the backhand side
by lowry just getting started two out
top of the first no score now here's the
01 pitch and that swung on a ground ball
into the shift lowry's right there to
field goes to first and for bassett it's
a one two three top of the first with
the a's coming up in the bottom now
we're on the bound for the diamondbacks
tonight the big right-hander john de
pontier third start for duke gonzo
looking for win number one yeah he's
definitely got to go out there and try
to keep his team
in the ball game keep the ball down and
try to heat up some innings today for
the d-backs
those are career numbers for john
deplontier
right there john deplontier rings up
canada and that's out number one two and
two on lowry with the dangerous matt
olson on deck
late on the fastball two batters two
strikeouts for john duplantier he didn't
look like he saw the ball that entire
back one two
swinging a grounder to the right side
it's the shortstop rojas who has it and
he will toss to first in a one two three
first for john declan we go to the
second christian walker leads off for
the d-backs first pitch from chris
bassett is hit in the air deep down the
left field line towards the fence it's
out of here
christian walker leads off the second
inning with a solo home run and the
d-backs have a one-nothing lead
nice job by walker got a slider up in
the strike zone that's just the seventh
home run given up all year by chris
bassett this is his 13th start second
for christian one-nothing diamondback
you got a little hanger right there 76
miles an hour jumped all over it so
here's vargas a well-traveled infielder
who was with the diamondbacks a few
years back and now he's back with him
runners at second and third the pitch to
vargas and the 1-1 on the way swung up
broken that loop short left elvis going
out as the play is there and he makes
the catch so bassa keeps the damage down
as the d-backs score one they leave two
and after one and a half it's one
nothing arizona
jammed him that time charged by rojas
got a hurry
and that's another ground ball out for
john deplontier nice play by josh that
time attacking this ball three hopper
comes in quick transfer and gets them
plenty of rocks and delivers
swinging a grounder to short rojas has
it double clutches throws to first still
has time to get cannon and the inning is
over chad duplantier there's not a lot
of hit yet he's got four strikeouts he's
got one walk
a pitch
swinging a grounder through the shift
into left field a base hit should say
against the shift really there were
three infielders to the right for lowry
and that little seeing eye base hit the
first hit of the game for oakland now
you're in a spot here 3-1 bases loaded
shawn murphy batting a cool thousand
with the bases loaded not to mention the
success with runners in scoring position
and it is inside he walked in so
trotting in the score will be lowering
we got a 1-1 game olson a third moreland
a second and murpher board at first base
and there's still nobody out and that's
going to be it torrey lavello is going
to go with the left-hander it's a
one-one game murphy first moreland
second olson at third and that one is
lying to left and that's the base hit
olson scores moreland will stop at third
and the a's have taken a 2-1 lead still
nobody out a crisp line drive to left
field in front of pavon smith still
nobody out and now here's matt chapman
and that one's hooked to left and that's
going to get down for a hit
moreland will score murphy will be held
up and now it's three to one six
consecutive a's have reached here
against the diamondbacks and this is a
storyline a movie that they've been
involved in probably far too many times
way inside and it's a walk that'll knock
home another run here's kenna bases
loaded one out four runs in 4-1 oakland
grounded slowly toward third escobar out
at second to throw to first not in time
and run scores pinder crosses the plate
it's 5-1 oakland as kanna stays out of
the double play and gets his 23rd rbi of
the year number two and that'll bring up
eduardo escobar 41 runs battered in
number two in the national league
entering today and 14 home runs and he
takes and that's it the knees ring him
up fastball strike three called and
bassett is really on his game now
and we go to the bottom of the six the
a's on top of the diamondbacks 5-1
nobody out here for the d-backs
walker with the lead of first base
and the 2-2
swinging a foul tip and held on by murph
and that's strike three to half a dozen
k's now for bassett little change-up
front door change-up as it turns out
josh reddick reddit getting booed a
little bit from the a's fans that
obviously for his role with the houston
astros
reddit got under it
pindering right walker's at third still
backing up out there it got into the
wind this will get a run home
peralta tags up and now has to hustle
back to first
it's a sacrifice fly for reddick and
it's now a 5-2 ball game so reddick gets
his eighth rbi it's now five to two two
outs here at the seventh here's the 01.
curve pulled the first and caught by a
leaping olsen tremendous play by the
gold glover as he reaches above his six
foot five inch frame and snares it in
the leather 3-2
ouch
it got booked or
vargas trying to recover
and they're able to get lowry one four
three on the put out an excellent play
by vargas and booker says he's a-okay
that caught him right in the keister
meester
this ball was smacked right in the
backside and a nice play by vargas
reacted to it i thought there was no way
they were going to get lowry but got him
by half a step the entire training staff
and
infield on the mount ryan eubanks yes
bats his game to win and duplantier's
game to lose now here it is and it's
swung on a fly ball short center elvis
going out bolt coming on sky vault
calling forward he's there and he makes
the catch
and these are back to 10 games over 500
they notched their 36th win